it is the other aspect where the simple
moments of the notion of organism are
compared at the moments of the outer
structure that would first furnish the
genuine law expressing the true outer is
a copy of the inner now because those
simple moments are pervasive fluid
properties they do not have in the
organic thing such a separate real
expression as what is called an
individual system of the shape or again
if the abstract idea of the organism is
truly expressed in those three moments
merely because they are not static and
our only moments of the notion and of
movement the organism on the other hand
as a structured shape is not
exhaustively dealt with in the three
specific systems into which it is
analyzed by anatomy insofar as such
systems are supposed to be found
actually existing and to be
authenticated by being so found it must
also be borne in mind that Anatomy
presents us not only with three such
systems but with a good many more
furthermore apart from this the system
of sensibility as a whole must mean
something quite different from what is
called the nervous system the irritable
system something quite different from
the muscular system the reproductive
system something different from the
intestinal mechanism of reproduction in
the systems of shape as such the
organism is apprehended from the
abstract aspect of a dead existence it's
moments so taken pertain to anatomy and
the corpse not to cognition and the
living organism in such parts the
moments have really cease to be four
they cease to be processes since the
being of the organism is essentially a
universality or a reflection into self
the being of its totality like its
moments cannot consist in an anatomical
system on the contrary the actual
expression of the hole and the
externalization of its moments are
really found only as a movement which
runs its course through the various
parts of the structure a movement into
wit in which what is forcibly detached
and fixed as an individual system
essentially displays itself as a fluid
moment consequently that actual
existence as it is found by Anatomy must
not be reckoned as its real being but
only that existence taken as a process
in which alone even the anatomical parts
have a meaning
as we start moving into paragraph 276
Hagel has been criticizing this whole
notion of law as traditionally
understood in observation of nature as
applied to the organic being we've seen
why the organic being presents certain
problems when we try to make it
analogous to things that are covered by
other physical laws now Hagel is in this
paragraph relating to bring out two of
his his main criticisms and they're
closely connected you notice I've got
this entire schema up here this by now
is quite familiar to you if you've been
following along with these videos we
have what it calls the simple moments of
the notion of organism or the inner
right the inner to the organism
sensibility irritability and
reproduction we've been talking about
those now for several paragraphs here on
the other side is what Miller translates
bye-bye outer structure the moments of
the outer structure the german term
there's the resulting gestalt dawn
should be and we've seen that Hagel's
using this term you stalled here to me
and the external structure so for
example the muscular system is a
structure the skeletal system is a
structure something that you can observe
you know you can cut it part of corpse
and start you know peeling lots of
things and seeing where the nerves run
and all that sort of stuff you do that
with humans and you can do that with
other animals you can do that with
plants the systems that they have never
read it in our own time have some very
very sophisticated techniques for
getting at more of the outer getting it
you might say some of the inner of the
outer but we're not getting at the
either itself so Hinkle is going to go
on in you know the ring is some very
important criticisms he says what's
supposed to be happening is that we've
got this law in place that the outer is
the expression of the inner and how does
that work out
the outer here right and we've got these
three moments of it these simple moments
and they're supposed to correspond to
what we can actually observe which are
these these three systems and these
systems are in a certain way supposed to
be not just an expression but kind of a
copy of what's going on over here
Hagel's going to point out a problem
with that right away these are what he
calls pervasive fluid properties this is
not something new but now you're seeing
some of the implications of that so he
says these are pervasive fluid property
so they don't have in the organic thing
a separate real expression he has what
is called an individual system of the
shape over here with what we can observe
like I said you can take my body now you
can kill me in the process but you could
take my body and separate out say the
muscular system from the nervous system
from the intestinal system from the
skeletal system from from other systems
as well right but you cannot do that as
Hagel has pointed out previously with it
a being in terms of these these moments
of its consciousness of what
consciousness that it has so what
implications does it have you says if
the abstract idea the organism is truly
expressed in those three moments merely
because they're not static and only
moments of the notion the organism is
not exhaustively dealt with in the three
specific systems into which it is
analyzed by a navvy now not the anatomy
of our time sure to take an anatomy and
physiology class q by a giant thick
textbook that costs you a lot of money
because there's a lot of systems being
examined but at the time these are the
main ones that the anatomist seem to be
interested in and correlated to the
basic functions of the organism so Hagel
is saying look there's two problems here
one is every single one of these is not
adequately accurately
expressed in its particular quarrel it
over here so sensibility is not going to
be found just in the nervous system but
as we saw again previous paragraphs
running throughout the entire living
organism now he's raising another issue
to which is that these three systems
aren't really enough it was tempting to
try to say well we've got three over
here so there must be three
corresponding over here but we've got a
remainder you might say right this
doesn't go into this without leaving a
remainder if we want to use the video
very loose metaphor of division because
there's other systems to the to the body
to the organic being so he goes on and
he says insofar as these systems are to
be found actually existing and to be
authenticated by being found we have to
bear in mind that anatomy presents us
not only with three such systems but
with a good many more so the question
that is all the other stuff that's over
here how do we read that back into
what's going on over here so nervous
system for example is being called into
question in two major ways does the
nervous system encompass or express all
of what is sensibility no and there may
be other systems that themselves are
closer or at least you know tangentially
related to Sensibility we can say the
same thing for each one of these so
handle goes Anatomy says the system of
sensibility as a whole must mean
something quite different from what it's
called the nervous system and again I
pointed out in a few past videos that
here the person who actually reminds me
of the most is somebody who didn't draw
are quite a bit from Hegel and that
would be maurice merleau-ponty the
french 20th century philosopher who was
also a phenomenologist studied on a puss
role but incorporated quite a bit from
Hegel merrell Ponte pointed out
perception does not simply reside in the
perceptive organs but runs throughout
the entire human being and we might say
similarly the other basic functions as
well your ability and the reproduction
at least as handled as conceiving it
here so he says in the systems of shade
that suctioning organism is apprehended
and here's the problem from the abstract
aspect of a dad existence and why is
that a big problem well what are we
supposed to be examining here are we
supposed to be looking at disease in San
cadaver or are we supposed to be
observing and understanding a living
organism if we're not actually getting
to a real organism here and by real I
don't mean that it has you know worldly
existence but that it truly is an
organism these systems aren't very
helpful to us and you know here's what
you can say in an anatomy textbook or
you know in an observation when you're
dissecting a cat the amber these are
quite discreet from each other and you
can see how they're working and we have
computer-generated models now where you
can see them inserted action but not
real action in order to see them as
living as the real being of the organism
we have to look at living beings and not
just at dead of things which happen to
be a bit more convenient and easier to
work on because they stay still because
they don't regal because they don't sort
of escape our the grasp of our reason so
he says since the being of the organism
this part over here is essentially a
universality or reflection in the south
of being of its totality being a
totality would be this entire thing the
inner and the outer the beating of its
totality cannot consist in
comical system on the contrary the
actual expression of the hole and the
external ization of the moments where
are we to find them this is where it
gets really interesting this is where he
go actually you might say prefigure is
somebody like iron bear song as well of
course no Ponty drew okay the beating of
the organism on the contrary the actual
expression of the whole are really found
only as a movement which runs its course
through the various parts of the
structure a movement in with what is
forcibly detached and fixes an
individual system displays itself as a
fluid movement moments are consequently
that actual existence must be its
founded by Anatomy must not be reckoned
as its real being but only that
existence taken as a process in which
even the anatomical parts have a meaning
so what does Hagel saying their Anatomy
is nice but it's at best approximate if
it can teach us things you know for
example I want to know how the elbow
works an anime can tell me a lot about
that but an anime can't tell me about
how the elbow works in its function in a
organism a living being that is you
might say mo doing that is you know is
air so called it a self moved mover to
some extent so the truth of these
external systems of the organism not
external to the organism but how it
externalizes itself already found in how
will the inner expresses itself in the
outer not the outer is mirror copies or
stand-ins for the inner
we see then that the moments of the
organic inner taken by themselves are
incapable of furnishing the aspects of a
law of being since in such a law they
are asserted of an outer existence are
distinguished from one another and
neither aspect could be equally named in
place of the other further that placed
on one side they do not find in the
other side their realization in a fixed
system for this latter would as little
possess any organic truth that is the
truth of organic being as it would be
the expression of those moments of the
organic inner the essential nature of
organic being since it is in itself the
universal rather consists in general in
its moments being equally Universal in
actual existence that is in there being
pervasive processes but not in giving an
image of the universal in an isolated
being
here in paragraph 277 Hale is saying
that we actually don't have a law that
applies to the organic that can capture
what he's calling here organic truth or
as a miller is glossing it in those
brackets the truth of organic VA which i
think is a legitimate thing to do
because Hagel just a little bit after
that talks about the essential nature of
organic being the Basilea you know of
organic being so what's very important
here is that Hagel is drawing some
further conclusions from the previous
paragraph and we should think about what
the failure of finding this law amounts
to for us is it merely a throw our hands
up and say oh well we tried observing
reason isn't really going to stop there
but it is encountering a setback and
we'll talk a little bit more about that
in the next paragraph with the
significance of that is here let's
concentrate on the thicker TV says the
moments of the organic inter taken by
themselves are incapable of furnishing a
law furnishing the aspect of a lot of
being why because in such a law there a
certain of an outer existence right our
existence here and there treatment as
being separate from each other even
though the reality is such that they
actually are interconnected within the
the being and what we're talking about
here is a what Hagel is calling a fluid
dynamism so insofar as the law that we
want here is you might say transposing
them in relation to these these fixed
systems that are supposed to be separate
from each other in the honor even though
they are fused into one organism they're
still distinguishable from each other
once you kill the organism in dissect it
we're distorting the the picture of
what's going on in this side so it
doesn't turn out to be a very good law
if the purpose of the law was to lend
intelligibility because
the very way in which reframing the law
is you might say falsifying this side
and this is actually in some respects
the side that we know the best because
we are organic beings we are organisms
and we have these these functions going
on so he says neither aspect could be
equally named in place the other placed
on one side they don't find at the other
side their realization in a fit system
because this wooden possessed organic
truth so it wouldn't it wouldn't provide
to us the truth of organic being the the
truth in a fuller sense not just in the
you know correspondence theory sense but
you might say in a global sense that
Hagel's interested in is not found in
the you know lowercase truths of anatomy
that you might find in a textbook or
being taught to univ course or you know
with a computer programmer platform so
the egos on tony says the essential
nature of our organic v8 since it is in
itself a universal remember we're
talking about here go back to those
previous paragraphs where the individual
being is indeed a universal hagel had
that paradoxical framing of this this is
where some of those those birds that
took off at that point come to roost
right this is this organic being is a
universal and he says its moments these
moments are equally Universal in actual
existence they are pervasive processes
but they don't give an image of the
universal in an isolated being so these
being pervasive proper my properties
processes there are properties as well
but being pervasive processes means i
like i said before sensibility runs
throughout the entire organism
reproduction does as well they fuse into
each other they're not distinct parts or
systems the way that we imagine them to
be because we're looking at the external
and trying to distinguish them apart
from each other and again i mentioned
before Aristotle says something similar
the day anima that the parts of the soul
are not really parts as such that you
know we'd be sort of imagine that sort
of structure to them but that's really a
function of our ways of observing so
hagel here is saying look if we're
trying to get at what the reality is
that the truth of organic being this is
more like what we've got and not this
over here which is supposed to be its
expression so the law is not going to
stand
in this way the idea of a law in the
case of organic being is altogether lost
the law wants to grasp and express the
antithesis as inter aspects and in them
the determinate pneus which is their
relation to one another the inner to
which the manifested universality
belongs and the outer to which belong
the parts of the inert shape we're
supposed to constitute the corresponding
aspects of the law but as thus held
apart they lose their organic
significance and what lies at the base
of the idea of law is precisely this
that each of its two aspects should have
an independent indifferent subsistence
of its own the relation of the aspects
being shared between them as a two-fold
determinate pneus corresponding to that
relation the fact is that each aspect of
the organism is in its own self just
this to be a simple universality in
which all determinations are dissolved
and to be the movement of this process
paragraph 278 is bringing this critical
examination of the law as conceived that
is applying to organic being to a close
and I want to think as we conclude this
little portion about what the the upshot
or the outcome now having attained a law
really ought to be understood as within
hagel system and also by analogy to some
other philosophers I'm thinking in
particular about Plato and the operatic
dialogue but let's see first where Hagel
is going he says that what we're trying
to strive for is this law of organic
being and he says that we've lost it
we've lost the idea of a long organic
being and wine well the Lord wants to
grasp the inner and the outer and we
said that you know it's been trying to
think of the relation between them as
this that the inner is expressed in some
way in the outer and we've seen that the
problem is is that it's taking
essentially an analogy working backwards
from the outer into the inner in the
outer we do hit up is he's calling it
here parts of the inert shape the
gestalt right or or as we call them
before the systems and those are
available to us by anatomical
observation the problem with that is
that when we try to read that back into
the inner we've seen that we can in fact
do that that's a possibility but there's
no guarantee that that's going to be
ready in you might say properly or
adequately you could say that that
observation gives us enough rope to hang
ourselves with and the problem is as we
seem all ready to fold we don't actually
know if a given part corresponds to the
totality
a function as it turns out it probably
doesn't the other problem is that we can
isolate these out from each other but
like Aristotle pointed out in his
discussion of the hand you could have
hand on from the body that's no longer
truly a hand it's a hand in an equivocal
sense it's no longer a dynamic organic
living system it no longer has its
functionality it's just in our meat and
so we're getting a false picture of how
things are on this end by looking at
this you know for example when we engage
in anatomy or you know something was
very popular back a little bit after
hagel psychometrics you know all these
these sorts of observational activities
the problem is that the inner doesn't
really manifest itself that way to
manifest itself as a universality so
that reproduction is running throughout
the whole of the Orient organism as the
outer but also pervading the entirety of
the inner and it's overlapping with
their interpenetrating with irritability
and sensibility and another whatever
other functions we have we've only
talked about three so far we could make
it more complicated if we want to I mean
previous philosophers certainly dead
right when I talk about the intellect
for example as a system in this way or
we might talk about other things in any
case the problem stands he says the
inner in the outer were supposed to
catch to the corresponding aspects of
the law but those held apart they lose
their organic significance they in the
process of trying to isolate them out
which makes good sense we lose our hold
on what they are he says what lies at
the base of the idea of this law is this
each of its two aspects should have an
independent indifference of systems on
its
the relation of the aspects being shared
between them is a two-fold determinant
is corresponding to that relation so
what it does is it sets up this you know
antithesis which is there between the
inner of the hour is gay intense right
contradiction say other part and it
treats this sign is inert and then it
also treats this side as inert it treats
them as actually separable from each
other when they are distinguishable but
naturally separable and therefore then
looks for the relation between them but
can really grasp what that relation is
and we lose the law or organic being you
know you could say here that in a
certain way what Hagel is doing is
stressing a point which Aristotle and
then Thomas Aquinas had made that being
distinguishable is not the same thing as
being separable from each other and so
in certain things if you do try to
separate them out you're going to screw
up your picture of them and one of the
main currents in modern philosophy in
pervading matches modern philosophy but
because of philosophies connection with
natural science and with the developing
social sciences or human sciences was
this notion that we well we begin by
separating everything out think about
Descartes and his rules of method they
were great for certain things do they
work great as a universal method no do
they work particularly well for organic
beings I don't think so and we can say
similarly for many other philosophers
now I did say I wanted to talk a little
bit about the implications of mapping of
the final lot like I put here sort of
the heading examining the law ended up
negating the law let's think about it
what negation means here just go back to
a galleon determination
all right not obligation is simply
wiping the slate clean and saying oh we
can't do to anything I want to say that
there's an analogy here between what
Hagel is doing and what is happening in
platonic operatic dialogues the operatic
dialogues are the ones the in which they
reach an OP chorea that is a place where
you're literally hemmed in and you can't
go any further so a lot of the earlier
dialogues of these ones that are assumed
to be earlier by the scholars are
operatic in that sense they they try to
figure out for example what courage is
in the lockets and they never actually
arrive at a satisfactory definition of
courage likewise in the Euthyphro they
try to figure out you know what piety or
holiness is and they don't arrive it now
what you have to ask there is are these
dialogues complete failures them because
they didn't attain the object and you've
got a skeptical point of view and you
interpret Socrates is sort of a proto
skeptic the guy who says yes I am wise
because I realized I don't know anything
that's only a little bit of Socrates
Socrates actually knows a hell lot and
he unveils that as they go along in the
dialogue there are with every operatic
dialogue some very important
achievements that happen along the way
and they're not all completely negative
saying well it's not this it's not this
it's not this there's a lot of knowledge
being exchanged back and forth but
because people are looking at that over
there they're missing what's happening
over here I would say something similar
is happening in all of these discussions
of law we are gradually learning more
and more about how Hagel conceives of
organic beings even though we're not
finding the law that we want to have so
what we've got going up here is a
determinate negation rather than just a
merely you know primitive negation let's
call it